on va se rendre très loin d'une galaxie
près de chez nous avec le télescope
spatial James web qui pourrait avoir
découvert cette forme circulaire rouge
en fait ce serait la galaxie la plus
distante jamais observée qui existait et
écoutez bien il y a 13,5 milliards
d'années alors on va essayer d'en savoir
davantage sur cette découverte
extraordinaire avec nous René Doyon
astrophysicien à l'Université de
Montréal directeur de l'observatoire de
l'acte mégantique directeur de
l'Institut de recherche sur les
exoplanètes bonjour monsieur Doyon
je suis sûr que vous avez regardé ces
images là avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'attention nouvelle galaxie qu'on
appelle glace Z13 qu'est-ce que ça
représente exactement
d'abord c'est une galaxie candidate donc
elle n'est pas encore confirmée d'être à
cette distance-là mais disons qu'elle a
toute l'allure d'une galaxie très très
lointaine et elle était obtenue avec Web
avec des données qui sont maintenant
publiques et donc c'est sa publication
là des chercheurs de harder qui suggère
effectivement ce petit point rouge là
vraiment toute la Lure d'une galaxie qui
s'est formée il y a 13.5 milliards
d'années donc on parle au tout début de
des premiers moments du Big Bang on se
rappelle que l'Univers était formé 13.8
milliards d'années donc lorsqu'on
regarde loin on regarde dans le temps et
donc oui ça a tout l'allure d'une d'une
première d'une galaxie très très
longtemps qu'on devra confirmer avec
d'autres observations qui sont qui vont
venir très très bientôt avec web comment
on peut en arriver à faire cette
hypothèse là on se voyant
les galaxies ont une des couleurs très
particulières et donc et donc en les
observant dans différentes couleurs et
on peut voir qu'ils ont cette apparence
là et c'est une analyse particulière
qu'il faut faire là mais encore une fois
c'est une gaine galaxie candidate et
pour vraiment confirmer qu'elle a cette
distance là il faut prendre un spectre
des données spectroscopiques vraiment
c'est qui sa lumière et voir des la
signature spectroscopique qui montre que
ce Galaxy là est vraiment à cette
distance là non et je précise aussi que
l'article était soumis a été soumis n'a
pas encore été revu par les Pères
normalement on se met un article donc il
y a tellement de de frénésie avec web
que les gens sont très impatients
de course on veut on va être les
premiers et bah les chercheurs donc
choisi de de tout de suite mettre leur
article public ce qui est correct mais
encore une fois faudra attendre que
l'article soit d'abord accepté et aussi
surtout pour vraiment confirmer ça
prendra des observations
spectroscopiques qui vont venir très
très bientôt et d'ailleurs laisse-moi
Canadien sera mise à contribution pour
confirmer en fait cet objet là de
manière spectroscopique avant d’accord
et il y a plein d'astronomes à travers
la planète j'imagine qu'ils plonge déjà
là-dessus pour essayer de confirmer ce
qui est écrit dans l'article ce qu'on
dit c'est que cette galaxie candidate
comme vous le dites elle nous apparaît
telle qu'elle était seulement environ
300 millions d'années après le Big Bang
qu'est-ce que ça peut nous dire ça
exactement concernant le Big Bang c'est
une des missions les plus importantes de
web c'est de comprendre comment les
galaxies les premières galaxies se sont
formés au début du big bag il a fait de
la théorie du Big Bang dit que l'univers
s'est formé à 13.000 milliards d'années
mais c'est passé une période où est-ce
qu'il y avait rien de l'univers tout ce
qui avait c'est du gaz d'hydrogène mais
pas vraiment de galaxies et il y avait
des endroits des régions qui étaient
plus dense que l'autre et avec la
gravité tout ça c'est effondré et les
premières une première lumière les
premières étoiles Galaxy se sont
allumées et on sait pas très très bien
quand ça s'est passé mais là déjà on
voit une galaxie candidate à 13.5
milliards d'années donc seulement 300
millions d'années après le Big Bang et
cette galaxie là a l'air d'une galaxie
relativement bien formé et donc ce qui
suggère d'autres qui se qui sont plus
jeunes qui a encore et donc c'est
vraiment extrêmement intéressant encore
une fois il faudra confirmer avec
d'autres données qui vont venir avec web
toute la puissance pour très bien
confirmer la distance de cet objet là et
ça pourrait se faire dans les prochaines
semaines en fait oui oui tout à fait en
attendant c'est sûr qu'on regarde une
certaine prudence en sentant qu'on a pas
de confirmation scientifique alors que
James web nous réserve j'imagine comme
ça là pour les années à venir pendant
encore 20 ans des découvertes cosmiques
assez surprenantes en terminant monsieur
le voyant absolument ça ne fait que
commencer on va suivre ça avec vous avec
grand bonheur merci beaucoup d'avoir été
là ce matin René Doyon Astro officiel
universel Montréal et directeur de
observatoire du lac Mégantic merci
beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]